When we think about the possible ratios we could obtain, we get the following.
We could take 1 over 1, and that would give us 1. We could also take negative 1
over 1. And that would give us negative 1. 1 over 4 gives us, well, 1 4th. 1
over negative 4 gives us negative 1 4th. And you'll notice that if we do
negative 1 over 4, we get negative 1 4th again. And negative 1 over negative 4
gives us positive 1 4th again. So because we have both a positive and negative
versions of each number in each set of factors, we're going to have a lot of
overlapping factors. This is convenient, because it means that we'll get less
in the end than it looks like we would get. The last two possible rational
zeros are one half and negative one half.